it takes 24 minutes to turn around a
Eurotunnel freight train full of imports
from Europe at the terminal near
Folkston it then leaves full of lorries
heading for the continent six trains an
hour 24 hours a day seven days a week a
quarter of all our trade with Europe or
100 billion pounds worth a year this is
the frictionless trade border with
Europe in action 99% of traffic
completely unchecked tariff free up
until now within the European Union and
it's single market and customs union
we've got fresh vegetables fish going
from Scotland
we've got processed food car parts
pharmaceuticals coming through in public
pharmaceuticals and in their checks
there nothing here will be checked
nothing over each other this is all in
true European transport that is friction
that's absolutely frictionless it's like
moving something from Manchester to
London there's no check on the motorway
you just take it from one depo you
deliver in another that's how it works
today and the single market deal you
have to check the plans yeah you've got
the customs you've got tariffs rules of
origin so when we're told not
frictionless but as frictionless as
possible what would that mean here the
as possible has to go the only way to
run this is frictionless yesterday Sky
News revealed that the government had
obliged key operators on the border to
sign non-disclosure agreements over the
shape of the post brexit border there
are no customs checks here this is
frictionless trade but there will be no
customs checks either whatever breaks it
brings because there can't be any
they're simply not this space and
privately the government is
acknowledging that because even if in 12
months time there is no deal what the
government is suggesting
to unilaterally not enforce legally
required customs checks what the
industry is nicknaming these throw open
the borders option how's that for taking
back control but all that presumes it
across the channel Europe would
reciprocate by not applying its own
Union customs law to what will then be
the third country of the United Kingdom
the freight trade is baffled by this
presumption in government disruption in
Europe trying to get to Britain is just
as much of a problem for Britain as
disruption here if we have massive
queues of the goods we rely on at Calais
not being able to get in and that's
going to be disastrous for us and the EU
is going to enforce the rules it has it
has to that's the way it works this
month the Treasury confirmed it would
take a pragmatic approach to border
controls to the Public Accounts
Committee the head of that committee
unimpressed if you have a two minute
delay on every freight vehicle that
could be 17 miles of tail back both
sides of the English Channel so you can
understand government wanting to solve
that but it's solving that throwing open
the borders to all players we said
you're not really taking into account
how people might change their behavior
for nefarious reasons to break the law
to do bad things to our country and it
is staggering after all this
government's con constant talk about
controlling our borders that we're faced
with a situation which could be fairly
open borders and chaos on day one even
if there is a deal outside the customs
union and single market goods
regulations checks will be required
somewhere this is the current customs
checking facility that serves the
channel toll and the Port of Dover a few
miles away off the m20 at stop 24 it has
just 82 lorry parking spaces as time
ticks down for credible solutions the
private sector has to make its own
decisions amid the uncertainty they're
having to set two different prices one
for now while we're still in the EU and
then a higher price whilst you're once
you're out of the EU because of
uncertainty until a transition deal is
actually nailed down and is legal and we
can say our members you can absolutely
rely on this then people have to price
for the possibility that there will be
no transition they have to try and put
procedures in place but they have to
price accordingly and the lack of border
plans is beginning to change minds
including the chair of aqui customs
consultative committee himself no fan of
the EU if it doesn't work what the
consequences the ports come to a
grinding halt really though when we've
had this apocalyptic predictions and
they don't come to pass is this not just
more of the same no I don't think so I
mean we're always warned that you
shouldn't use the word disaster when
you're talking to the politicians
because they're immune to it and really
this there's been no there's been
nothing like this at all me you paint
quite a dark picture of where this could
go if the government does get a grip of
the customs situation and yet you voted
leave I did what I didn't vote for what
it appears we're gonna get now although
but simply something is amiss the money
is not being spent the planning
permissions not being sought nor the
customs officers being trained let alone
shovels in the ground to build the new
facilities inescapably required by the
government's decision to leave the
single market in customs union instead
the government is signing secrecy
agreements about unilateral plans widely
dismissed by the people who actually
operate the frictionless border with 12
months to go and transition not a legal
certainty something has got to give
and soon vital Islam Sky News in Kent